people of the web and people of death
pianeta terra questi signori del planet
centrati su sixty parsec che sarebbe
contenuti sixty seconds dove ci sono i
nostri personaggi che sono rinchiusi in
una cabina nello spazio devono
sopravvivere
giochiamo che bello ogni volta che mi
parte sixty passo si sa con c'è la
musichetta che mi dia troppo bene a new
adventures l'ultima avventura ha fatto
schifo quindi partiamo bene che è meglio
alla space thrill voyager osservai vol
voyager scegli un capitano scelgo a io
posso scegliere capitano scegliamo lui
nomi come si chiama beni bronco
attributi agilità intelligenza non mi
sembra troppo intelligente in realtà
però va bene e forza vuol dire che non
mi fa fare l'inizio dove corrono io
voglio correre voglio prendere le cose
fa mi corre famiglia farà parte iniziale
dove devo prendere le robe ponga ragazzi
non ho ancora capito gioco come sia
possibile che l'acqua non ci deve
interessare come sono brevi veroncora
andrai prendiamo la roba e tanto posso
prendere di roba fighissimo a un attimo
un attimo cavolo sempre di subito lo
vedrai e ho preso un calzino che è la
ovviamente i calzini volete non prendere
i calzini quando dovete sopravvivere
servono tantissimo
devo prendere questa che ora al telefono
c'è qua raccontano dopo prendere è
fortissimo quindi ci sono anche quelli
che hanno gli attributi per quando corri
all'inizio che prendi e robben non lo
sapevo c'è un'altra zuppa qua spiega la
prendo la soap è utilissima perché sono
schiacciamo di fare ai miei vieni prendo
cose io no quella roba non posso
prendere o demoni è morto enunciato
forse ce la faccio non ci prova solo
foto è stato veramente difficile
no non ce l'ho fatta ma come rafa forma
dai facciamo finta che ci abbiamo fatto
taglio finché non iniziamo a giocare e
jajalo sapeva forza pipolo mai chopin n
ellis di di dawkins poi c'è tom thompson
che sempre innegabilmente continua a
fissare sta povera crista e ci sono io
che sembra che ciò otto anni in realtà
neo 27 e faccio ancora
lo youtuber andiamo avanti ragazzi
allora giorno 1 stavolta vi si affaccia
800 zuppe che madonna santa la mensa a
scuola vostra in confronto è un tutorial
crafting unavailable alla tua madre è
veramente brutta cos'è cosmo ma in
computer
porcaccia vacca l'ora di andare avanti
capitano ognuno deve dalla propria
abilità io do sempre la forza perché dio
mio sembro the rock
quindi diamo la forza bravo vede i baby
broncopolmonite end of the day non posso
fare niente il primo giorno non si vede
che la nave si deve assestare ma va bene
così vabbè ragazzi alla scoperta di
mondi nuovi siamo l'ultimo rimasuglio
dell'umanità quindi siamo rimasti in
quattro siamo gli ultimi esseri umani
sono io e capitano non farò in modo che
l'essere umano si estingua quindi
tranquilli è successo o no siamo stati
hackerati maledetto aranzulla pure nello
spazio che possa riciclare gli oggetti
creare non creiamo le cose tipo questo
perché dovrei creare un calzino parlante
non lo so però va bene anzi forse è
meglio creare il duct e ce l'abbiamo
d'arte abbiamo usato o perfetto abbiamo
captato 15 abbiamo che cosa abbiamo
preso la è successo abbiamo controllato
l'asteroide e abbiamo visto che c'era
della zuppa la zuppa e universale va
bene ok abbiamo rubato la zuppa da
ranzuglia e ha smesso di andarci e dire
che meglio di così
poi c'è fame l'altro ci ha fame la fame
io c'ho farne ma non video ancora una
sega o direi che siamo messi molto bene
raga perché abbiamo otto miliardo di
cose hai realizzato che non sei solo hai
visto la il contorno di una persona
nell'oscurità sembra senza emozioni
matti sta fissando fai qualcosa riguardo
a questa cosa no perché in realtà sarà
la maschera cioè non vedo maschere pro
sarà una maschera antigas
sono affamato affamato ha fatto ancora
niente zuppa questo sta trattando il
calzino che richiede un sacco di tempo
giustamente buonanotte
speriamo che non schiatti non è da una
settimana che non mangia non c'è proprio
vabbè giorno 7 non mangiate mai infatti
sta morendo tutti
lui si sta un po cagando addosso in
realtà però qualcuno ha disegnato la
terra sulla navicella perché allora
diamo da mangiare asti cristiani one two
three four let's go
vediamo cosa succede c'entra niente
perché io da da mangiare quindi
tranquilli il tipo è tornato a fare il
farfallone con la zia tutto ok
voglio organizzare un party epico siamo
rimasti solo noi quattro all'interno
dell'intera umanità quindi perché no
ecco ragazzi attivi in consiglio nei
commenti
non ho mai capito se quando loro hanno
fame angri vuol dire che non stanno
morendo starving vuol dire che stanno
morendo così hanno solo fame se hanno
solo fame mi conviene carina starving
giusto per che cosa li do da mangiare
adesso devono ancora arrivare vostri
successivo o sono più bravi se sono non
affamati non lo so non l'ho mai capito
male noi andiamo avanti
e stato un super partiva bene prossima
volta che adatta la festa disegnate sul
calzino degli occhi sono messe tra posto
va bene
next ho capito come si gioca è
fichissimo vanno capisci come si gioca e
data faccio ancora schifo però molto
meglio della prima volta primo contatto
zitti zitti zitti quella che c'è una
roba quali si muove lo vedo sono
disturbato capitano e sta parlando il
computer
ho sentito un bambino piangere nello
spazio ma i miei sensori non hanno visto
niente quindi non dovrebbe essere un
bambino magari stata un'allucinazione è
causata dallo stress e della guerra
nucleare guardare nello shuttle
assolutamente sì troviamo i bambini
morti
no vivi non lo so troviamo ciao a tutti
fa ecco adesso sono in starving tutti
quanti quindi posso dargli da mangiare
la zuppa c'è lotta questi sono alieni
sono dei ho trovato aiuto ho trovato
degli insetti con la boccia da
astronauti sono insetti astronauti min
chiara quello che c'è sul letto la
scorsa settimana ha ammesso a guardar
netflix
stavo guardando io ero disteso li
guardavo li porta l'acqua uguale solo
che c'è alla boccia sopra ci sono degli
insetti che sono sopravvissuti
all'apocalisse nucleare lo zio si sono
imbarcati con noi sono grossi
intelligenti e molto più dannosi degli
altri della loro specie vuoi provare a
ucciderli come gli lascio vivere perché
se prova ucciderli sono fortissimi
quindi lasciamoli vivere magari ci
aiutano
non lo so so sto dubbio stanno morendo
tutti di fame quindi diamo da mangiare
non muoiono perché gli insetti li
ammazzano tipo ti prego non ucciderci
ti prego ma dopo giorno d'oggi avesse un
botta uscire la scritta se ne sono
andati sicuro gli insetti hanno
apprezzato la nostra
il nostro approccio di pace ok ci hanno
creato un arma cosa ci hanno creato un
arma ci hanno scritto sul fogliettino
non possiamo mangiarla quindi
prendetevela con amore i peterson
avevano un cognome simoni peterson va
bene bues captain stiamo approcciando ad
un pianeta che sembra essere molto
simile al nostro bene i miei scanna non
hanno rilevato forme di vita ma ci sono
delle strutture sulla superficie che
potrebbero essere disabitate atterriamo
e preghiamo in gesù cristo
posso craftare il telefono che portiamo
il telefono va bene
e intanto scendiamo vai
signori vi conosciamo le dita
atterraggio
che bello posso vedere il canada chissà
se ciò non internet e la madonna
muto o pià allora ragazzi siccome 238
non l'ho fatto subito adesso non sono
mica scemo possiamo andare in spedizione
visto che siamo su un nuovo pianeta sono
quattro punti di esplorare possiamo
andare in di ogni punto in un punto
diverso del pianeta e ti dice cosa puoi
guadagnare quindi elettricità kitsch i
pericoli quindi solo l'ambientazione è
quanto ci mette a per tornare la persona
che la spedizione quindi tre orologi
mafiosi al 3 giorni deserto tre giorni e
possiamo incontrare dei polipi immagino
siano alieni maiale swamp e vai tu
invece fissa la tizia ok questa sono un
sacco di skill trattamento la tizia
let's go così la tipa se ne va in
spedizione noi mangiamo tutti contenti
ancora sono tornati peterson ciao
ragazzi che bello siamo ritornati borga
adro e ha male al padre puoi parlare
peterson assolutamente sì sono nostri
amici da un sacco di tempo
porca vacca e avrei anche bisogno che
quella tipa ritorni perché sono questi
mi schiattano di fame sperimentiamo
hanno sviluppato un modo per utilizzare
l'energia ci sono più intelligenti noi
peterson va bene non facciamoci domande
dato crea la zuppa do da mangiare a
tutti tranne la tipa che non ha tanta
fame quindi effetto and day
io vorrei se possibile trovare un modo
per scappare lo straw pianeta visto che
siamo qua da sei anni
non lo so c'è modo di scappare o
possiamo stare qua tutto il tempo 25 no
no come
ma perché mi è morto lui aveva sempre
lui e finisce
no mi chiamo martire lui così è rimasto
quello che continua a fissare la tizia
sono rimasti solo loro due come ma no
dai perché di addirittura alla fine che
peccato ci ha mandato più 37 di energia
e peterson maleti peterson
porca vacca dovete mangiare di peterson
juve rist che peccato era un pianeta
egiziano fighissimo quindi ragazzi
abbiamo provato è stato difficile però
mi piace usa questo gioco cioè vi giuro
nipote ci gioco è molto più difficile
c'è già sixty seconds è difficilissimo
questo è veramente un casino allucinante
e dire che non c'è manco l'acqua prevede
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa lasciato
momento mi piace anche per i peterson
perché sono molto intelligenti e
guardano i miei video sono gli si chiede
e noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo vito da
ragazzi
[Musica]